have you talked to Tyler yes I sent him
a message when his dad was it but not
anything else in that nothing else
relationship me yeah anything you want
to say okay wish him I'll wish him well
looking back I mean look you had the
drink you had the hangout then he went a
different way do you think he could have
handled that better like did you have
any warning he was gonna date somebody
else so quickly I think we were both
single and it is his decision to do
whatever makes him happy and so I want
my own happiness and okay are you over
it I'm moving forward okay
um my atlast bachelor a question look we
saw Jed's true colors came to light
looking back do you think Tyler was in
it for fame at all I can't say I don't
know I think I think that he is a good
guy and has a good heart
Edie with Hanna be at her first Dancing
with the Stars fitting it is so surreal
yeah I'm so excited this is really fun
how are rehearsals what's the hardest
part about it Wow okay so I was the girl
that was like in all my shoes
all right as we start I have not been
the best idea at first because I had the
biggest blisters I've ever seen hurts so
bad finally got them babied them a
little bit but I think it's just
learning something completely new
because ballroom dancing is so
articulate and your hips have to be a
certain way and legs have to be straight
at one time event another and I am
unfortunately a perfectionist at heart
and so it's really hard to allow myself
to not be good to get better and I want
to just be good right off the bat and
that's like nothing happened
[Applause]